- Depuis le début de
la campagne électorale,
le NPD répète cette affirmation
quand il est question de
changements climatiques.
Est-ce que le Canada est
vraiment le seul pays du Groupe
des 7 où les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre ont grimpé
dans les dernières années?
♪ ♪ ♪
C'est vrai, les émissions
ont bel et bien augmenté
depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir
de Justin Trudeau, mais pas
dans les autres pays du G7.
En 2015, on a rejeté
723 mégatonnes de gaz
à effet de serre au pays.
Ça a baissé à 707 mégatonnes
l'année suivante et, puis,
ça a recommencé à grimper.
On a atteint 730 mégatonnes
de GES en 2019, un niveau
plus élevé qu'au moment de
l'entrée en poste des libéraux.
Selon les dernières données
disponibles, le Royaume-Uni,
l'Allemagne, la France,
le Japon, l'Italie et
les États-Unis ont tous réussi
à réduire leurs émissions.
Le Canada est donc le seul
du pays du G7 qui va dans
la mauvaise direction.
- Hello, everyone!
- Au printemps, Ottawa
s'est fixé une nouvelle cible
dans le cadre de l'Accord
de Paris sur les changements
climatiques : réduire
de 40 % les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre
par rapport aux niveaux de 2005.
Pour y arriver, le Canada va
devoir retrancher 295 mégatonnes
de GES à son bilan carbone.
En raison de la pandémie,
les émissions mondiales
ont chuté en 2020, mais
les experts s'attendent
à un rebond important en 2021.